he's a singer song or record producer
dancer and actor people call him the
King of Pop his 1982 album Thriller is
the best-selling album of all time he's
Michael Jackson and here are his top 10
rules for success
my favourites are on the album is man in
the mirror oh yeah
that's that's my favorite song I tend
the whole I feeling that no matter what
you do in the world it really has to
start with you is my philosophy - if you
want to make the world a better place
take a look at yourself and then make a
change is it's all you do yeah well
people don't look at themselves honestly
they don't look at themselves and point
the finger it's always the other guys
fought or somebody off you should change
yourself look at yourself
make better of yourself huh my purpose
oh boy I think to give in the best way I
can through song and through dance and
through music I mean I am committed to
my art I believe that all art has as his
ultimate goal the union between the
material and the spiritual the human and
the divine I believe that to be the
reason for the very existence of art and
I feel I was chosen as an instrument to
just give music and love and harmony to
the world
I remember having the guys go back in
and create more innovative this we don't
this is our thing we don't a lot of
sounds on the album that are found from
keyboards that are you know pretty much
programmed into the Machine and
throughout and make our own stone mm-hmm
get on things we beat on things so
nobody can duplicate what we do we make
them with our own hands we find things
and we create things and that's the most
important thing to need to be a pioneer
be an innovator okay
what's going through your mind when
you're dancing not thinking thinking is
the biggest mistake a dancer could make
you have to feel you become the face you
become a fanfare you become the clarinet
the flute in the strings and the drones
so you're almost the physical embodiment
is absolutely believe in yourself study
the Great's and become greater no matter
what I don't care if the whole world is
against you Ortiz you're so you're not
going to make it believe in yourself no
matter whatever some of the greatest men
that made a mark on this world we're
treated like that you know you're not
going to do it you're not going to get
anywhere they laughed at the Wright
brothers they'll add the Thomas Edison
they laughed at Walt Disney they made
jokes of Henry for they said he was
ignorant you didn't have a college
degree as he dropped out of school he
hasn't dropped out of school
they took forward to court to prove his
intelligence
that's our limit yeah and he's a minute
shaped and changed our culture our
customs when you live really do think
most important stay humble human the
humbleness that a child like a newborn
baby has even though you become powerful
or or have power with the people with
your talent or with like you know with
what Michelangelo did was sculpting you
know underneath all that be as humble as
a child as a baby and it's kind and
giving and loving never become puffed up
with pride how do you write a song how
do I write a song well
you don't I said Indiana what would
happen if i sat here and played some
courts whatever and say I'm going to
write the best song ever written nothing
happens something in the heavens has to
say look this is the time that this is
going to be laid on you and this is what
I want you to have it now I remember
when I when I wrote Billie Jean I was
riding in my car down Ventura Boulevard
all I said to myself beforehand I want
to write a song what a great bass hook
you know and and I just let it go really
and in several days later you know out
and I'm doing do um do you know what hmm
bung sow okay you you were singing the
bassline sing that again and then what
happened how did you get the other
instrumentation and the composition how
did it work it
see the thing is in artists seem to get
in the way of the music get out of the
way of the music you know don't write
the music let the music write itself I
mean with any type of creation you
create what's inside of you
subconsciously what influences you I'm a
fantasy fanatic and anything that take
you off into another world escapism
that's what I like um I'm not so crazy
about the reality of everything I like a
lot of fantasy and that's what I try to
create to get away to become moved
they come I think what they get for me I
get from them
I told I've said it many times my
greatest inspiration comes from kids
every song I write every dance I do all
the poetry I write is all inspired from
that level of innocence that
consciousness of purity and children
have that I see God in the face of
children and man I just love being
around that that all the time you have
something within your records that
everybody just loves why I couldn't say
I just created and honor to the public
in your what I do I couldn't explain why
the anatomy or why it happens there's a
formula not that I know of I is my heart
I put my heart in it you put your heart
in yeah Michael Mitchell
I know the creator will go but it works
with eyes that is like to escape death
Anton Devine my soul
I came along
I mean what do you put into it well
whatever I think that's that mean with I
can sing a song I don't think it if I
don't mean it thank you guys so much for
watching I made this video because
random order asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Michael
Jackson's top ten rules you liked the
most
leave it below I'm going to join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching we need to believe and I'll see
you soon